you want to bite i've added my spices i
love it frying these up i love the okra
oh geez and there it goes it's amazing
this is what we got that's what i'm
talking about you can't go wrong when
you have heavy cream you add the saffron
i'm hannah i'm the world's okay mom i'm
out with my chickens right now we have
done a week of foods around the world
but every time i'm kind of loved wanting
more from each country so i want to try
something new so for one entire week i'm
going to cook just foods from india wish
me luck i chose india this time because
when i was sourcing recipes you guys
came through with so many indian recipes
so many requests so really i didn't
choose india you did so the rules are
i'm gonna show one dish for each day
because i'm making these dishes in big
quantities a lot of these recipes take a
decent bit of time to cook so i'm gonna
make big batches and utilize my
leftovers and rule number two go get
yourself a snack because these videos
all make everybody hungry you will be
hungry i will link the recipes if i have
them some of them are family recipes
that i can't share but if i got it off
the internet you can find it in the
description now i went with the most
popularly requested recipes on my
instagram but then i also tapped my
friend annie cat for some help
oh there's henry hi henry he works for
buzzfeed india and he knows so much
about indian food because i wanted to
make sure i wasn't just picking dishes
from a specific region in india i think
the biggest misconception the west has
about indian food is that it's only
butter chicken paneer dal stuff like
that which is extremely
north indian there is so much
you know rich food and flavors from from
the east from the west from the south of
the country so it's really comforting to
talk to someone who actually
knows the food a lot better than me
that's such a cool experience to have to
experience so many different cultures
right in your own kitchen that's that's
really good well thank you so much
making something really
different for me for dinner tonight
you're welcome sweetheart i'm making
aloo bindi tonight which is a potato
okra tomato curry i started out cooking
some potatoes this is what's out of my
comfort zone i've never cooked or eaten
okra okra is a really slimy vegetable
when it's raw and so you want to make
sure you're cooking it long enough to
get rid of all of that slime now this
dish uses one of the most recurring
seasonings of the week garam masala
which is one of the most delicious
flavors i've ever had in my life i was
nervous to serve this to the boys
because not only is it a new recipe but
it's also their first time eating okra
are you excited to try
yeah
it's really good
[Music]
i like it
it's a very
different type of vegetable but honestly
it's really fun to eat
is it good it's fantastic have you had
okra
yeah
do you like it wow but yeah it's great
the kids loved it which was such a
relief because i wanted to start this
week off on a good note and this really
was the right recipe to kick it off
because it was something unique
fun and tasty
wow
it's a really mild
delicious curry i love the okra
and i love the potatoes with this um
you want to bite you can't have it it's
mine and this for me it was my favorite
dish of the week as most of you know i
don't like to eat a lot of meat and so
the beauty of indian food is there are
so many tasty vegetarian recipes and
this one was ten at a time six cups of
milk next up i tried my hand at making
sog paneer now soft paneer
henry's five okay
now soft paneer is really common on
indian restaurant menus out here in
california i don't know if that's the
same across the states but it's a
northern indian dish that is really
popularized in the u.s basically i
curdled some hot milk with vinegar and
that turns the milk into curds and whey
which i did not
i've never made my own cheese i've heard
curds and whey in songs and i thought
they were fake like i didn't know this
was a thing but basically the curds are
the white chunkies and the whey is the
clearish
water okay you see how it's starting to
turn clear here what's the way
so you want the curds and whey to
separate but you want the whey to be
clear not milky like this
and that's when you know it has finished
after separating the curds from the whey
i used a cheese cloth to strain
everything out and then i had to hang it
for several hours to make sure all the
way dripped out of those curds all right
it really doesn't seem like the most
secure but this is what we got once all
the way was out it was time for me to
form this cheese into the flat
shape of paneer paneer is usually
sliced into chunks like cubes so i
needed to flatten it out so it wasn't in
a ball and so i waited the cheese down
and
smoked for the past
[Music]
oh there we go
and put something heavy oh my goodness
we do what we can here we make it work
and we improvise okay this has been
pressed for over three hours
oh
what oh my gosh wait
this is like cheese
okay wow
it's a legit cube of paneer the paneer
is supposed to marinate in some spices
and oil while i prep the rest frying
these up i've got onions and minced
ginger cooking i've added my spices and
a little bit of water and i'm gonna cook
these for about four minutes i almost
forgot to make rice i'm gonna put a lid
on this
got my spinach oh steamy my spinach in
here this looks super super fresh
finished product grown-up plate
little kid plate
i bought none
and i can already tell this isn't going
to cut it so you know what that means
tomorrow
yeah i'm making none how's it going
jackson it's amazing
have you tried your food
how is it
good okay this is the true test though
oh yeah
see
if matt likes it
[Music]
it's good i like it it's much more like
more
spinach seems healthier like it's more
like big pieces of spinach
oh it was heavenly it was so good and
really making the paneer made it so
worth it
this is super good now after making the
paneer myself i decided to make my own
naan okay there's my flour my yogurt oil
a little salt and then i'm going to pour
my foamy
yeast water
oh geez and there it goes
that's what happens when i try to film
let's try oh geez stop spilling out
this is where i feel like i'm in over my
head with this try two hands probably
should have put my hair up before i
started this
but here we are
okay this isn't looking
oh it's like super
hard i don't know if i did this wrong
i am not a seasoned indian cook my arm
muscles are weak puny pathetic excuses
of arms and so i was really struggling
with kneading this dough
this looks pretty good about eight
inches it's really thin so i'm gonna
throw this on a hot skillet i don't know
if you can tell but she is puffing up
this looks like non let's see if it's
burning though it's supposed to be like
kind of charred not quite definitely
didn't give this one enough time put
some ghee on this
so ghee is clarified butter and you'll
see it a lot in indian cuisine okay
that's what i'm talking about
look at all those
dark spots a little sample
[Music]
non
doll
brown rice and you can eat with your
hands if you'd like
how's the naan
amazing
what do you think
let's see the other side of your knot
it got really
crisp oh perfect
everyone was so happy with it even wyatt
loved the doll
and he's kind of my anti-vegetable guy
as you know and he's not the most
receptive to new things
but the key really is educating him
about the different countries where the
food comes from and then he's a lot more
willing and excited to try so he was
totally open-minded about the lentils
and loved them
[Music]
um this nana is pretty good
for our first try i also just need to
add that this is my first time making
these dishes i am not the expert in
indian cuisine i am the one seeking help
so don't watch what i'm doing and think
wow
that's all real indian food no it's my
first attempt at making indian food can
you tell i just woke up from a two hour
nap i don't feel good today but that's
okay i'm gonna power through and keep
cooking tonight i'm going to try to make
butter chicken
do you want to see what i'm cooking look
this is yogurt
no no no no oh my gosh now butter
chicken is a tomato and cream based
sauce with a marinated chicken if you've
had butter chicken before it is a real
treat it's really tasty and i don't eat
a lot of meat and specifically chicken
but i will eat
chicken when it comes to
trying some of these
dishes from other countries so the
chicken marinates in yogurt and spices
it makes sense to me because it is such
a tangy creamy texture i actually
remembered to start my rice
progress
i usually forgot to the last minute this
is getting lots of nice brown bits at
the bottom of the pan
you farting yeah
okay
chicken is slightly browned
now i'm making the sauce it was really
really good i mean you can't go wrong
when you have heavy cream like it is so
delicious
wow
that looks amazing
you want a fork honey yeah you don't
want to eat it with your hands here's
the thing guys you can eat with your
hands if you'd like or you can eat with
a fork okay
this is one of their favorite recipes of
the week it's a classic dish it's a fan
favorite there's a reason why it's one
of the most popular recipes out here now
matt is really the one who we need to
hmm
oh this is
amazing
delicious
hi bree what do you think
thumbs up
yeah
what do you think guys
this is good i love it
i have another kiss
i'm making something i've never heard of
this morning i never heard about it
until aniket told me about it and then i
did get i got the the poha okay perfect
you got the chin forehead
is the best oh god
oh i'm so i i literally didn't know what
i was doing like a rice flake flattened
rice
kind of like if you took a grain of rice
and rolled it out and then
dried it and it's a breakfast that can
be paired with chai something i bought
for this specifically is mustard seed
i've never cooked with this before so
i'm really excited to see how this
tastes um i soaked my poha a little like
i rinsed it and i tossed it in salt and
sugar
[Music]
what do you need
i toasted mustard seed and cumin and
waited until they were popping it was
like a little popcorn on the pan and
then i added my onions my potato
this dish used turmeric to turn it a
really delicious golden color once that
was cooked i finally added my poha and
let's get the chai started before i
forget so chai is actually pretty simple
to make yourself it's black tea cinnamon
peppercorn cardamom and cloves and you
can find all of those spices pretty
easily and then you can either grind
them up and or i chose to boil a lot of
them whole with the black tea and it's
just a mixture of hot water and hot milk
you boil it with sugar until it's the
color you like depending on how strong
you like it and then you strain it all
out
look how the cardamom pods opened
while boiling
it's pretty dang good did you put makeup
on your face yeah
yeah i think the boys first thought it
was scrambled eggs when they looked at
it because it looks so much like a
scramble but it's nothing they've ever
had before so i truly didn't know how
they were gonna react at all because
it's something completely new and
unfamiliar i'm going to try try
try the try
[Music]
what do you think henry
um
now let's try pokemon it's called poha
which
is good
let's see
how does it go with the chai yummy
oh thumbs up
yeah and to my absolute shock they
started shoveling this in like
henry shoveled this in and he's pretty
picky and he absolutely loves this
are you trying it this is so good did
you try the chai
so it's a breakfast served with chai
you ate oh you ate the cilantro again
i'm not surprised everybody likes this
oh my gosh this chai is so good
oniquette told me once i make that chai
myself i'm never going to want to buy it
again and he was so spot on right
because it was really easy and made a
nice big batch it was so tasty and just
the real
spice that you're supposed to taste when
you're drinking chai i will never buy it
again it's dessert time i'm making here
which is kind of like a rice pudding
um and i'm very very excited to make
this myself i'm gonna start by rinsing
this rice
and then i'm gonna soak it i decided to
just use almonds in my cure instead of
cashews and pistachios because i really
wanted the flavor of the rice and the
milk to be in the forefront and the
other thing i did was omit the raisins
because i
hate
raisins if there's one food that i think
should be illegal it's raisins i started
by heating my milk and then i poured it
over some saffron the cool part about
this though is the saffron is red
and then when you pour the warm milk on
it the milk turns a really really bright
yellow color you basically heat rice and
milk together add some cardamom sugar
and nuts of your choice and raisins if
you want and then you just keep stirring
it until it's thickened and then at the
very end you add the saffron and the
soaked milk back in this looks about the
correct consistency
this is here
[Music]
it's kind of sweet
but savory
it's a rice pudding
it's cardamom you're tasting
oh my gosh
this is really good i love this it's
really good
that's good this is why i want to live
in india
you want to live in india yeah well i
think we certainly should visit right
hi
this is definitely one of our favorite
desserts of all time it is so good it's
not like any rice pudding you've ever
had before my only thing i would change
is i'm going to make a bigger batch so
at the end of a week of cooking indian
food i am a little bit tired i think
that this week really highlighted how
lazy i've gotten when it comes to
cooking food so really forcing myself to
put in all that extra effort and really
make so many things from scratch
kind of reinvigorated me to
take my time with meals i also really
thought that we would end the week
feeling like
we had a full picture of what indian
food is like
and again this is just leaving me
wanting to try more so i want to send a
huge thank you to everyone who sent me a
recipe to aniket who helped me through
this process really it wouldn't be
possible for me to teach my kids in this
way or for them to have these
experiences without your help so i
really really appreciate it so that's
all for now i'm hannah and if you liked
this and you want us to see us try foods
for a week from your country
message me on instagram and give me some
recipe suggestions and if you have any
more indian recipe ideas or any tips or
tricks about the food that i did try to
make message me that on instagram as
well now if you'll please excuse me i'm
in a nap for a hundred years because i
truly feel like garbage sewer rats
till next time
[Music]
you